- Okay… Wir müssen besser und
schneller spielen.
Besonders die Technik ist bei uns allen
schlechter geworden.
Außerdem …
- … höher springen und mehr Tore schießen!
- Du lachst.
Wir machen gleich weiter mit Sprints.
- Ja, Max, wir wissen Bescheid.
Du bist der Schnellste.
- Okay, Max ist vielleicht am schnellsten,
aber ich kann am weitesten schießen.
- Ah!
- Und Tarek …
… spielt am schlechtesten. Ja, ja, ich muss
mich trotzdem erst mal ausruhen.
- Ausruhen? Gute Sportler
machen dreimal pro Woche Training.
- Ich mache Krafttraining!
- Das wichtigste ist die Ernährung. Iss viel
Obst, trink keinen Alkohol und rauch nicht!
- Und trink viel Wasser!
- Gut, ihr Fitnessprofis.
Dann zeigt mal, was ihr drauf habt!